So the first thing I want to show you is
this thing called a golden board.
Now they have the,
this was worked out by Francis Gulf
who's actually quite an interesting
person.
You'll,
you'll see if you hear about Francis
Galton,
you'll often hear that he was the first
person he tried to measure human
intelligence.
But that's actually not true.
What golden tried to do was measure
human eminence and he thought of eminent
says,
I suppose something like high position
in the cultural dominance hierarchy.
And this was back in Victorian England
in the late 18 hundreds and so eminence
would have been intellectual
achievement,
financial achievement,
um,
cultural achievement,
achievement,
broadly speaking,
but really considered within the
confines of a dominance hierarchy.
So at that point in time,
the English regarded themselves as the
prime nation and ethnicity on the
planet.
And then the aristocratic Englishman
regarded themselves as the prime human
beings in that prime country and
ethnicity.
And so it was really an idea that would
be more associated with,
with dominance hierarchy,
upper most dominant hierarchy position
than anything we would conceptualize as
intelligence today.
And Goldberg,
our golden was a polymath.
He was a genius in many,
many fields and got very interested in
the idea of measuring human differences.
And uh,
he tried to determine whether the
differences that he could measure in
some of those things where like reaction
time and height and,
and uh,
uh,
physical fitness and,
um,
I can't remember all the other things
that he attempted to measure,
but he wanted to see if any of those
things could be used to predict
eminence.
Um,
it turned out that they couldn't,
partly because eminence is not the kind
of category that you can make into a
scientific category.
Um,
and partly because his measurement
instruments in many ways weren't
sensitive enough.
He didn't make enough measurements and
the statistics weren't sufficiently
sophisticated.
But the idea that you could measure
elementary attributes and that you could
use them to predict something important
was still an important idea.
And it's one of those examples in
science,
sort of like phrenology.
I mean everyone makes fun of phrenology.
Now.
You know,
the idea that you could read someone's
character by mapping out the protrusions
and depths and so forth on the,
on their skull,
it sounds
ridiculous to modern ears,
but there was,
again,
there was some idea behind it and that
was the idea that critical functions
could be localized and that cognitive
functions could be differentiated into
separate functions.
We still do that.
We think of emotions and motivations and
personality traits.
And intelligence is,
even though intelligence is,
is not a very good idea,
the idea that you can differentiate,
um,
human psychological function and then
that would be related in some way to the
underlying neurological and physical
architecture.
That's not a stupid idea.
So an idea can be very intelligent at
one level of analysis and not so
intelligent that the others.
So I would say the problem with that
phenologist was actually a problem of
operationalization.
They had the theory right in some sense,
but they didn't have the measures right.
Um,
now one of the things Bolton who came up
with was the normal,
he came up with this thing called the
golden board.
And a golden board demonstrates how a
normal distribution is produced.
Now basically what the normal
distribution is a,
an axiomatic,
it's an axiom of modern statistics and
every system has to have its axioms.
And the axiom of normal distribution is
basically the idea that around any
measurement there's going to be a set
of,
there's going to be variations in
measurement and those measurements are
basically going to be random.
And then another axiom is that extreme
outlying measurements are going to be
rare and small outlying measurements are
going to be more common.
So you can imagine,
um,
if I measured any one of you a hundred
times with,
uh,
with,
let's say with a tape measure,
I'm going to get a set of variables that
are not always exactly the same.
And so there'll be an average and then
there'll be some deviation around that
average.
And if I looked at a hundred
measurements that I took of each of one
of you,
then I would get a normal distribution
around that,
that distribution,
and that's sort of the fuzziness of the
mean.
Now that might be partly because my
measurement instrument isn't very
accurate.
It might be partly because at some point
when you're being measured for the 50th
time you're slouching a little bit or
maybe other times you standing up a bit
straighter or maybe I measure you in the
morning sometimes and in the evening at
other times.
If you're actually taller in the morning
than you are in the evening because your
spine has a chance to decompress at
night,
so maybe that adds half an inch to your
height in the morning.
And so there's,
there's going to be shifting and
movement around the,
around the central tendency around the
average.
Now if I turns out,
if I measure all of you,
the same thing's going to happen.
What we're going to get is an average
height,
which would be the average height of the
people in this room,
and then there's going to be a
distribution had basically a normal
distribution.
Those of you who are much taller than
the average are going to be much fewer
than those of you that are close to the
average,
and those of you that are much shorter
than the average are going to be.
There's going to be far fewer of you
than there are going to be.
Those of you who are just somewhat
smaller than the average.
Now,
generally the idea of a normal
distribution is predicated on the idea
that the variation around the average is
actually random and that's an important
thing because the variation around that
average is not always random.
Now,
psychologists will tell you and and so
what most social scientists who use
classical statistics that the normal
distribution is the norm.
Or maybe they'll say more than that,
is that it's the standard case that
whatever set of variables you measure is
going to come out in a normal
distribution.
And that means that you can apply all of
the stats that you're going to learn to
decompose the world and reconstruct it
to your data sets because the data sets
will fit the assumptions of the,
of the,
um,
statistics.
The problem with that is that it's often
wrong.
Now,
I asked you guys to buy the Black Swan
and we haven't talked about the black
swan much yet,
and I'm not going to test you on it,
but I would recommend that you,
that you read it,
especially if you're interested in
psychology because you gotta watch your
axioms.
And the idea that the normal
distribution might not always be correct
and certainly might not be a correct
description of your data,
is a fundamentally important idea.
Because if it's wrong,
if your doubt isn't normally
distributed,
then the phenomena that you're looking
at isn't what you think it is and the
statistics that you're going to use
aren't going to work.
Now this came as quite a puzzle to me at
one point because it turned out that
when we,
when we produced the creative
achievement questionnaire,
um,
you know,
and,
and you'd think I would've known better
if by this time,
cause it was,
it wasn't that long ago.
It was like 15 years ago.
The data never came back,
normally distributed.
It came back distributed enough in that
what they call a pareto distribution,
which is everyone stacks up on the
lefthand side and the,
the curve drifts off to the right.
And that's one of those curves where
almost everyone has zero or one and a
smaller minority.
People have very high scores.
Now when you get a prieto distribution,
there's something going on that's not
random and that doesn't mean you can
ignore it.
Now,
one of the things that psychologists
will do sometimes if they get a
distribution that's not random is
they'll do it.
And mathematical transformation like a
log rhythmic transformation to pull in
the outliers and to try to make the data
fit the normal distribution.
Again,
assuming that there's some kind of
measurement error there or that the
scales got a logarithmic function,
um,
it isn't always obvious that that's a
useful and appropriate thing to do
because it's the case in many situations
where the extremeness of the
distribution is actually an accurate
representation of,
of the way that that phenomena behaves
in nature.
Now I want to show you how a normal
distribution works.
Um,
have,
have you ever,
have any of you ever seen a
demonstration of why a normal
distribution is normal in why it takes
the shape it takes?
Does anybody ever seen that?
No.
It's weird day because you think that
given it's unbelievable importance,
especially in psychology where
everything we do is measured and has an
average in a standard deviation,
that there'd be some investigation into
why we make that presupposition.
There's a great book.
One Book I would recommend for those of
you who might be interested in
psychology is a career.
There's a book called a history of
statistical thinking.
Now you'd think Jesus,
if there's not anything more boring than
statistics,
it's gotta be the history of statistics.
But it turns out that that's really
wrong.
I mean,
the history of statistics is actually
the history of the social sciences and
not only of the social sciences,
because statistics became not,
statistics was actually initially
invented by cosmologists who are
measuring planetary position.
And then the statistical processes that
have been used to underpin modern
science have been tossed back and forth,
weirdly enough,
between social scientists and physicists
over about the last 200 years.
Because the physicists ended up having
to describe the world from a statistical
perspective,
right?
Because if you go down into the realm of
the atomic and subatomic particles,
what you find is that things behave
statistically down there.
They don't behave deterministically and
it's the same at the level of the,
of the human scale.
You know,
we behave statistically not
deterministically.
So you know,
sometimes you hear this old idea that
that psychology has physics envy or
something like that.
But it turned out that for much of the
history of the development of
statistical ideas,
physics had psychology envy,
which I think is quite funny.
So anyways,
if you look at this book,
historic history of statistical
thinking,
you can see how the idea that
populations could have behavior in that
populations could be measured and that
the idea that states like political
states could be measured and that human
behavior could be measured.
And I didn't realize until I wrote,
I read this book that,
um,
how revolutionary the idea of statistics
actually was because of course it's part
of the idea of measurement.
So I had this very interesting client at
one point,
he was an old guy and he'd been a
psychologist and that finance,
you're anna statistician and he was in
love with mathematics.
You know,
he was one of these guys who,
who for whom mathematical equations had
this immediate glimmer of beauty.
And he made this very interesting little
gold sculpture that I have up at my
office,
that that's a representation of what
people claim to be the most perfect
mathematical equation ever constructed.
And He,
so we made this little gadgets like a
religious icon almost.
And,
and that's really what he thought of it.
um,
uh,
I'm afraid foolishly enough that I can't
tell you the name of the equation.
Some of you might know it,
it,
it relates I e and Pi.
Is there anybody in here who yes.
What is that?
Yes.
And what is that equation?
Okay.
And do you,
do you,
do you know why it's such a remarkable
equations?
I won
in one equation,
right?
So he thought that that in some sense
this equation summed up the magnificence
of the mathematical universe.
And so it was so funny cause he also
made little pins that people could wear
of this,
of this equation that we are also made
out of gold.
And there was another person in our
department at that point and uh,
I was wearing this pin around and she
said,
oh well she told me what the equation,
but she pointed,
you did that.
And she got all excited because it was
this perfect equation that related all
these fundamental constants to one and
zero.
So anyways,
he taught me a lot of this while he was
a client of mine.
He was very much obsessed with Matt
mathematical ideas.
He couldn't get them out of his head.
It was a true obsession and a useful
one.
But he had,
he taught me a lot of things about
statistics that I just never knew it
all.
And,
uh,
one of them was the prieto distribution,
which would just,
it just staggered me that I didn't know
it.
I only learned this stuff about five or
six years ago,
and it just made me feel like a complete
moron because I've,
you know,
gone through men,
Manz,
mother's psychological training.
And I was measuring things like
prefrontal ability and intelligence and
personality and creativity.
And then in the creativity measurement,
I stumbled into these prieto
distributions.
I thought they were bloodied mistake.
I didn't know what the hell they were.
You know,
when I've also found economists who
didn't know about the credo
distribution,
which is pretty bloody bizarre thing,
like it really is a strange thing.
So anyways,
one of the things he showed me is how
the normal distribution comes about.
And,
uh,
I had a student who did a phd thesis on
Gulfton,
so I knew something about golden at this
point.
He was,
he was doing a part of his thesis on the
history of the measurement of
intelligence.
And a golden was a key figure in the
establishment of that sort of
measurement.
So,
um,
but this is one of the things gotten
invented.
So let's take a look at it here.
Okay.
So that's your basic rock and roll
golden board apparently.
So let me show you a picture of,
of a golf board so you'd get a better
sense of exactly what is doing.
So there's a good one right there.
Let's see if we can make that a little
bigger.
Yeah.
So basically all that happens within
Goldman board is that you have a,
you got a bunch of pains on a board.
It's the board is horizontal and you
dropped balls down at marbles or
whatever it is and the marbles come in
one place and then they bounced down the
pins and they distribute themselves in a
normal distribution.
Now,
the reason they do that is because there
are far more ways of getting down the
middle.
Then there are of getting either side.
Now you see,
because to get to the only to the right
side,
say the ball has to go write,
write,
write and then fall in the Little Cup
and then on the left it has to do
exactly the same thing.
There's only one way it can do that,
right?
But to get into the middle,
it can go left,
right,
left,
et cetera.
There's a,
there's a far greater number of pathways
for the ball to go from the middle down
to the middle.
Then there is for the bowl to go to the
sites.
And so all that means fundamentally is
that the probability that a given ball
is going to land in the middle or near
the middle is much higher than the
probability that a ball is going to land
in the extremes.
And so it's just a description of how
random processes laid themselves out
around a mean.
Okay,
so that's a normal distribution.
Now if you have normal distribution one
and you have normal distribution to,
you can overlap them.
Right?
And if they overlap perfectly the mean
and the standard deviation or the same,
then there's nothing different about,
you know,
cause one thing you want to ask as well
are how do you know if two means are
different?
And the answer is you don't know unless
you know what the means are measuring
and you don't know what the means are
measuring unless you know the variation
of the measurement.
And so you have to know what the mean
and the standard deviation.
So the standard deviation is like the
width of the meme in some sense.
And all statistics do generally take one
normal distribution and another and slap
them on top of each other and then
measure how far apart they are,
how much they overlap and correct that
for the sample size.
And then you can tell if the two
distributions are different,
significantly different.
So what you would do is you'd run a
whole bunch of normal distribution
processes by chance and you're going to
get a distribution of distributions in
some sense.
And then you can tell what the
probability is that the normal
distribution that you drew for group aid
is the same as the normal distribution
that you drew for group B.
And that's all there is basically to s
two standard group comparison
statistics.
And that's how we decide when we have a
significant defect.
If there's a significant difference
between two groups or better still,
if you randomly assign people to groups
and then you do an experimental
manipulation and then you measure the
outcome,
the means,
then you can test to see whether your
experimental manipulation produced an
effect that would be greater than
chance.
And then you infer that,
well there's a low probability one in 20
that you would,
you would,
um,
produce that effect if you were just
running random simulations.
And therefore you can say with some
certainty that there's an actual causal
effect that's with an experimental
model.
Now,
hey,
you know,
why do you think,
all right,
let's say,
let me give you a conundrum.
So I used to study people who were sons
of male alcoholics.
Okay?
Now there was a reason for that.
We didn't have women.
Why might that be?
We didn't use women.
Why,
why,
why would they be confounding part from
the fact that they're women?
I supposed to be a joke.
You know,
Jesus,
it's a better joke than that.
Okay.
Well it could be that it was some sort
of emotional coping mechanism difference
between the way that deal with the
father daughter relationship is
different then.
Okay.
Well so that,
that's a part that's not about Aaronson
but it's,
it's not the answer that was appropriate
for our research.
And I'll tell you why because you
couldn't infer it from the question we
were interested in what factors made
alcoholism hereditary cause it does seem
to have a strong hereditary component.
And what we basically concluded after
doing a tremendous amount of research
was that people who are prone to
alcoholism,
at least one type of person who's prone
to one type of alcoholism,
God,
a very,
very powerful stimulant effect from the
alcohol during the time that their blood
alcohol level was ascending in the 10 or
15 minutes after they took a drink.
Especially if they took a large drink
faxed or multiple large drinks fat.
You can probably tell.
By the way,
if you're one of these people,
if you want to go do this and the bar
the next time you go,
go on an empty stomach,
take your pulse,
write it down,
drink three or four shots fast,
wait 10 minutes,
take your pulse again.
If it's gone up,
10 or 15 beats a minute,
look out because that means alcohol is
working as a psychomotor stimulant for
you.
And we found that for many of these
people that was an opiate effect.
What seemed to happen was that when they
drank alcohol fast,
they produced probably Beta endorphin,
although that we were never sure we can.
It can be blocked with Naltrexone,
which is an opiate antagonist.
Anyways.
The other characteristic of that pattern
of,
of alcohol consumption is that the,
the real kick only occurs when you're on
the ascending limb of the blood alcohol
curve.
So you know,
first of all,
your blood alcohol goes up and then it
goes down.
And generally when it goes down,
it's not pleasant.
That's when you start to feel hung over
and hangovers actually alcohol
withdrawal by the way.
So it's like heroin withdrawal,
acceptance,
alcohol withdrawal,
and it's generally not pleasant for
people.
So they usually sleep through it or it
puts them to sleep.
But if you're one of these people who
get a real kick on the ascending limb of
the blood alcohol curve,
then you can just keep pounding back the
alcohol and it'll keep hitting you and
keep you in that position where you're
at.
You know,
on the on ass ending part of the blood
alcohol curve.
And you can probably tell if you're one
of these people,
if you can't stop once you get started,
you know,
so if it's like you have four drinks
quick and it's like,
man,
you're gone until the alcohol runs out
or until it's four in the morning or
till you've spent all your money or
you've been at last bar in town or that
you're sitting on your friend's bed
after everybody's going home from the
party and you're still drinking,
you might suspect that you're one of
those people.
And if you are one of those people,
well then you should watch the halo
because,
um,
alcohol is a vicious drug.
And it,
it gets people in its grasp hard and
it's hard for them to escape once they
do.
People also drink to quell anxiety.
So now the problem,
because we were looking at the genetics
of alcoholism,
it wasn't easy to study offspring of
alcoholic mothers.
And the reason for that is they might
have consumed alcohol during pregnancy,
in which case that's a bad idea.
Especially there's certain key times in
pregnancy were even a few drinks are not
good.
And that's turns out,
if I remember correctly,
that turns out to be the times when the
fetus is producing the bulk of its
hippocampus tissue.
And so anyways,
so if it turned out that daughters or
sons of female alcoholics were markedly
different from the general population in
some manner,
we wouldn't be able to tell if that was
a consequence of alcohol consumption
during pregnancy or if it was,
it was a genetic reflection.
So what we want it to do was study sons
of male alcoholics and so their mothers
actually couldn't be alcoholic and we
wanted their fathers,
the best subjects had an alcoholic
father and an alcoholic grandfather.
And at least one or more alcoholics,
first or second degree male relatives
and they couldn't be alcoholic and they
had to be young.
So because obviously if they were 40 and
they still work alcoholic,
then they probably weren't going to be
alcoholic.
So we wanted to catch them,
you know,
between say well it had to be 18,
which was,
it was in Quebec.
That was even a little late probably.
But you know,
that's best we could do from an ethical
perspective.
So we used to bring these guys into the
lab and get them quite drunk.
Um,
the National Institute of Alcohol is,
I'm an alcohol abuse,
pretty much put a stop to that research
because we used to bring them in and you
know,
we'd get their blood alcohol level up to
0.1,
2.1.
It had to be pretty high.
It actually looked like the real
physiological effects seem to kick in
when,
uh,
when people hit legal intoxication.
So you don't really get the opiate
effect till you park yourself up about
point your weight,
which was the legal limit for driving at
that point.
Um,
so we used to get,
some of these guys were pretty big.
They come in there and maybe 230 pound
guys to get them up to,
you know,
0.1 or 0.2 you had or 0.12 you had to
give them quite a bit credit,
lack of alcohol and then what we usually
do is we let them sober up till the
point it will six bout that and then
we'd send them home in a cap.
Well when the Eni Aaa got all ethical on
the whole situation,
they wouldn't let us send them home
until they hit 0.02.
It was like,
well,
if you're a 240 pounds and we've just
nailed you with enough alcohol so that
your blood alcohol level hit 0.12 you're
going to be sitting in our bloody lab,
bored to death,
feeling horrible for like six hours or
seven hours and you'd be pretty damn
irritated about it.
It's like it wasn't obvious how we were
supposed to keep the people there.
It's like,
well,
can I leave?
No,
I'm not paying you if you leave.
It's like that's going to produce real
positive outcomes,
but with like drunk people in the lab,
that's going to work really well.
Of course then they never come back
either because it was such a bloody
awful experience.
So I stopped doing that research partly
because it became impossible anyways,
we did find out a lot.
We found out that there was this one
particular pattern of of alcohol abuse
that seemed to be hereditary,
so every couldn't study it.
Women.
Anyway,
so now there was a problem with this
line of research and the problem was,
well,
alcoholism comes along with other
problems.
So this was correlational research,
right?
We take,
we,
we pick a group of people and we've
matched them.
The sons of male alcoholics,
we'd match them with people who weren't
sons of male alcoholics.
So they were still sons.
They were still the same age,
but their fathers weren't the alcoholic.
Now here's the problem.
What should we match them on?
Age,
gender?
Well,
you can't match them on number of drinks
obviously because
you want the people who are alcoholic in
one group,
not to be,
you don't want to alcoholics in the
second group.
So do you match them on number of
drinks?
Well,
if you don't,
then you don't know if this effect that
you're measuring is a consequence of the
genetic difference or on the number of
drinks per week or drinks per occasion
that the people had.
Right.
That'd be a confounding variable if you
match them for antisocial personality or
anti-personnel anti social personality
symptoms because lots of people who are
alcoholic have they tilt towards the
antisocial side of the spectrum.
So do you control for that while you
don't know because you don't know if
antisocial personalities part of
alcoholism,
like it's part of the same underlying
genetic problem or if it's a secondary
manifestation or if its consequences
drinking,
you don't know any of that.
Do you match them on depressive
symptoms?
Do you match them on schooling?
You match them on education.
Do you match them on personality?
Do you match them on other forms of
psychopathology?
Do you match them on what they drink?
Do you match them on how many drinks per
occasion they drink when they drink,
et cetera?
Well,
the answer to that is you don't know.
And so what that means is there's
actually an infinite number of potential
covariants
because you don't know what differences
there are between the two groups are the
differences that are relevant to the
question at hand.
Now that's actually one of the big
problems with psychiatric research.
In fact,
it might be a problem with psychiatric
research that so serious that it cannot
be solved.
You know?
So if you take kids who are attention
deficit disorder,
say this is horrible,
diagnosed a criteria and you match them
with kids who aren't and then you look
to see what the,
what makes the adhd kids different,
what do you match them on?
Well you don't know.
And that is,
so usually what happens is the people
who do psychiatric research
finance this a bit,
they matched them on the important
variables,
age,
physical health,
maybe education,
but the poor.
The problem is you actually have no idea
what the important variables are.
And there are an unlimited number of
them.
And so that's actually why random ass I
nation to groups is so important.
Now,
if I take all of you and I say,
well,
let's look at the effects of alcohol.
So what I would do is I'd say you'd come
towards me and I do a golden board
sorting.
You go to the left,
you'd go to the right,
you go to the last,
you go to the right.
This says nonbiased separation of the
two populations.
And then maybe I'd give one group two
ounces of alcohol and water and the
other,
or in coke say,
and in the other group I put a few drops
of alcohol on the top of a glass of
coke.
So it smelled like alcohol and tasted
like alcohol when you had your first
drink.
And then I put you through a whole
battery of neuropsychological and
personality tests,
which I did by the way,
to a bunch of people would think it was
the first publication I had back in
about 85 or something like that.
Um,
random ass I nation gets rid of the
necessity for the infinite number of
covariates,
right?
Because you're all different than a
whole bunch of important ways.
But we can assume as long as I threw
half of you in this group randomly and
half of you in that group randomly,
then all your various idiosyncrasies,
no matter how many they are,
our would cancel out.
And that's the massive advantage to and
mass I nation.
Now,
one of the things you're going to notice
when you go through psychology,
especially if you do the
psychopathological work,
is that the studies are almost always
correlational.
And they do,
they'll do,
they'll coat,
they'll control for relevant covariates.
That's what it will say in the paper.
But the problem is you don't bloody well
know what the ran the relevant
covariates are.
If you did,
you'd already understand the condition.
You wouldn't have to do the damn
research.
So you can make a pretty strong case
that all psychiatric research that is
studying psychopathological groups
compared to act control,
it's all not interpreted them.
And it turns out in that kind of
research that who should,
who the control should be is the killer
because you don't know picking the
psychopathological populations easy,
you just pick them according to whatever
diagnostic checklist you happen to use.
But when you figure out who to control
them against,
it's like,
okay
siblings,
I mean,
what are you,
what do you do?
What do you,
how do you have match a population and
answer his account.
So anyways,
the reason that we didn't include women
was because
of the,
uh,
um,
the uncontrollable potential con
confounding effects.
And the only way that you can do that is
to assign randomly.
And that's an important thing to
remember.
It's why experimental designs are way
more powerful than correlational
designs.
And the problem is frequently in
psychology,
what you see are correlational designs.
Now I think if you're careful and you
dig around and,
and you know,
you're obsessively careful,
you can extract information out of
correlational studies,
but it's no,
it's no simple thing to do.
You see this problem come up too.
When you hear about studies on Diet,
you know it's like,
well you should eat low fat diet or you
should eat a high fat diet.
Or usually what happens is they track
people across time who hypothetically
have been having one diet or the other.
But the problem is you don't know what
the hell else.
It makes those people different.
And the problem with that is there is an
infinite number of potential things that
make them different.
And that's a big problem.
The probability that you've picked,
the one thing that makes people who have
a high fat diet different from other
people and that it happens to be that
they have a high fat diet.
And that's the only difference.
It's like,
yeah,
no,
not at all.
Definitely not.
So,
okay,
so anyways,
random ass I nation gets rid of the
problem of the infinite number of
covariates and that's worth knowing.
And then the other thing that we've just
figured out is that,
you know,
if you make a measurement,
you're going to get a distribution
around the measurement.
And if you do that in two groups,
you can check out the overlap between
the two groups and you can determine
what the probability is that that
overlap is there as a consequence of
chance.
Now you might say,
why not set your probability level two
like one in 10,000 so you can be
absolutely damn sure that the two groups
don't overlap.
You know,
so why wouldn't you do that?
Why wouldn't you set p equals 0.0001
instead of p equals 0.05 so that would
be one in a thousand instead of one and
20 yes,
yes,
that's exactly right.
So you're basically damned if you do and
damned if you don't,
which is a very important thing to
remember about life because generally
when you make a choice of any sort,
there's error and risk on both sides of
the choice.
Right?
It's really,
really useful to remember that because
people always ask,
act like their current situation is
risk-free,
which is never ever the case.
Yeah.
So people were trying to figure out,
well,
how do we balance the risk of finding
something that doesn't exist against the
risk of not finding something that
exists and the reason it's one in 20 and
why is that?
It's because someone made that guests 40
years ago or 50 years ago and it's just
stuck.
There's no reason.
And so the other thing to notice is that
you want to be careful about the p
equals 0.05 phenomena.
Because one of the things you'll see is
that people treat any experimental
result.
They get,
like it's significant if the probability
is 0.05 or less.
And it's not if it's 0.06 or greater.
And that's not smart because the cutoff
is the cutoff is arbitrary.
You need to know three things to
interpret an experimental result.
It's like you,
it's like you can't calculate the area
of a triangle without knowing three
things.
I think it's three things anyways.
Um,
you need to know the number of people in
the study.
You need to know the size of the effect.
So that would be the relationship
between two or more variables that
you're interested in looking at and then
you need to know the probability that
you would find that effect size among
the population of that size by chance.
And you cannot interpret one of those
numbers without the other two.
It's not possible.
And now psychologists,
the status statistician's amongst
psychologists who have a clue,
I've been jumping up and down for 50
years trying to get psychologists to
report all three of those every time
they report anything effect size,
which seems logical,
right?
The effect size is the difference
between the two means divided by the
standard deviation of the entire of the,
of the pool group.
Well,
you need both of those because it's the
standard deviation that tells you how
damn big the man the numbers are.
Because what is 70 mean?
Well,
it doesn't mean anything.
70 it's like if I just came out here and
said that you,
I could say 70 and 40 are those
different?
Well,
what the hell does that mean?
It doesn't mean anything.
You need to know what the units are and
the distribution gives you the units.
And so once you know the units are,
you can say,
well here's how big the differences
between these two groups and here's the
probability that that would be acquired
by chance.
And so that's how confident you could be
that it's an actual difference.
And so you want to always report effect
sizes and most of you are going to be
taught to look at the damn probability.
And that's stupid.
It's like when you want to know how,
how tall,
how much difference there isn't height
between two people.
You want to know how much difference
there is in height.
You also might want to know to what
degree that's there because of chance.
But it's the effect size.
That's the critical variable.
Now you can't understand the effect size
without understanding how many subjects
were in the experiment and also the
probability that you would acquire that
by chance.
So you want to keep that in mind.
And when you're reading scientific
papers,
you want to be looking at the effect
size,
how large an effect size is this?
Now I teach all the effect sizes are you
can transform one into another.
So yeah,
of correlation coefficients which go up
to one,
you have the square of the correlation
coefficient,
which is the amount of variance that's
accounted for.
And that also goes up to one and you
have your basic correlation.
Your basic correlation coefficients are,
sorry,
your,
your standard deviation effect sizes,
which is mean one minus mean to over the
standard deviation of the entire group.
And so large effect sizes and psychology
I've talked to you about this before,
are correlation coefficients of about
0.5 or above or r squared's of 25% of
the variance,
which is 0.5 squared or um,
uh mean one minus mean two of say half a
standard deviation or greater.
And you can derive that conclusion that
those are relatively large effect sizes
by looking at the distribution of the
effect sizes across the published
literature.
And most of you will be told estimates
for effect sizes that are actually way
too large because those were guests as
to how big is a large effect size.
Well,
some statistician guessed 50 years ago.
So it's just like the point of five
rule.
It's arbitrary,
but doesn't mean it's stupid,
but it's arbitrary and you don't want to
get stuck on it.
Like it's like it's some sort of fact.
Okay,
so
now
let's look at um,
pareto distribution.
Okay?
The first thing you're going to see
about a prieto distribution,
because it's definitely not normal.
Now,
one of the things that I mentioned to
you before,
but I want to hammer this home because
it's,
it's unbelievably important for
determining how to understand the way
the world lays itself out.
And how do we interpret the way that
people distribute themselves in terms of
their success across time.
Now,
this is a,
this is a fundamental law and I'll,
I'll show you how it works.
Okay?
So their law is most of you get nothing
in a few of you get everything,
okay?
So that's the law.
Now you might say,
well that's because of,
you might attribute that to various
things.
So for example,
if you're a left wing,
your,
you attribute to it,
to the inequities of the social
structure.
And if you're a right winger,
you basically attributed to the fact
that while most people are not that good
at anything,
it's no wonder they end up with nothing.
So they're not very smart and they're
not very hardworking,
so they don't get very much of whatever
it is that thereafter.
Okay?
So
we'll take that apart a little bit.
But before we do that,
I want to show you an animation.
Now
you got to watch this wound care for the
hell.
Yes.
That's
okay.
Yeah,
this thing moves very,
very quickly.
So
go back to the beginning and
all right now.
So here's the deal.
Each of you gets $10 okay?
So that's a non random starting likes,
right?
You're all starting in the same place.
That's definitely not random,
okay?
Now here,
here's how you play this game.
You flip a coin,
you turn to your partner and you flip a
coin.
And if,
uh,
it both comes up heads,
then you win and they lose.
And if it comes up tails and heads,
then you lose and they win.
And if the winner gets a dollar from the
loser,
okay?
And so you can imagine that this is a
simulation.
So basically it's like your age training
bananas.
If you,
if you,
uh,
give away a banana,
then you're done with the banana.
So one of your walkaway with 11 and one
of you will walk away with nine and then
you turn to someone else who just wander
around the room and randomly trade.
Okay?
So what happens?
Well,
the first thing that happens is this.
Okay?
So we started the graph with everyone at
10.
No,
you've done a bunch of trades.
Um,
we don't know how many trades you've
done,
but a fair number.
And so what happens,
what you see happening is some winners
are starting to emerge right on the
right hand side.
Those are the people who've won every
single trade.
Maybe they've traded 10 times,
so now they have 20.
And then there's the people on the other
side who've lost nine out of the last
trades.
Now what?
What happens when you lose nine?
What's the big problem that you have?
What happens?
You only have $1 left.
So what happens if you lose another
trade?
That's right,
you hit zero and zero is not a number
like any other number.
Zero is like the black hole of numbers.
You fall into the zero hole and that's
it.
You're not in the game anymore.
And poverty is like that.
It's like that.
It's a kind of a trap and it's very,
very difficult to get out of.
So,
and it seems to be in part because once
you fall off the charts enough,
a bunch of things start conspiring
against you.
So for example,
um,
you don't have enough money to buy a
large amount of decent food cheaply,
so you have to buy expensive junk food
in short term.
So that might be one possibility.
Or let's say you end up on the street,
well you can't even get a job then
because you don't have an address and
you can't get social security because
you don't have an address.
Like things start to conspire against
you very badly.
Or maybe you're unemployed,
you've been unemployed for a year and a
half because it's been a prolonged
downturn in the economy.
Well,
if you're 17,
who the hell cares?
But if you're 50 that might be that for
you,
right?
You've hit zero,
you'd been out of the market for 18
months,
nobody's gonna hire you.
And so you've hit zero.
And the problem is we don't know what
the hell to do.
When people hit zero,
it's difficult to pry them out of zero
and throw them back in the game.
Now you could say,
well,
what if you just rearm them with money?
And that would actually work if the game
was truly random.
But it isn't obvious that the game is
truly random.
And that's where things get weird.
Okay.
So anyways,
by this point in the game,
there's some winners piling up and
there's some losers planning up.
What,
what's the difference between the people
who have 19 and the people who have one?
Well,
we know the one people,
they're going to be wiped out.
They got a 50% chance,
a hidden zero.
What about the 19 people?
Uh,
uh,
right,
exactly.
So they're in this place where the
basically sitting pretty,
they can fail nine times and that just
puts them back to where they were to
begin with.
So,
okay.
So we keep playing
well.
So you see what's happening is that with
repeated random play,
the normal distribution turns into a
[inaudible] distribution and most of the
population stacks up at zero.
Hmm,
okay.
This old guy I told you about,
he had a theory of social structure that
was predicated on this.
There's a bit of a Marxist twist to it.
He thought that what happened is that,
so if you ran a game long enough,
most people will stack up at zero and a
few people have everything.
Okay,
so let's say now you're down at zero.
What's your best strategy?
Well,
you might say,
well,
we should reset the game,
right?
Because if you're at zero and it's
basically a random game,
if you wipe out that game and you put a
note in another one in place,
there's some probability that when the
next game starts playing,
you're not going to end up at zero.
And that was his theory of revolutions.
Fundamentally,
once the,
once the game played itself out in until
resources,
we're maximally distributed.
It didn't cost the people at the bottom
anything to be revolutionaries because
they aren't already hit zero.
And so one of his hypothesis was that
one of the things that
political and economic systems have to
do,
they have to figure out how to do,
is to make sure that the people who end
up on the zero side of the distribution
don't have nothing to lose.
Because if you have nothing to lose,
God only knows what you're going to do
next.
Now it's a big problem because merely
shoveling money down there is not likely
to change the outcome very much.
Yes.
I was to say that sounds a little bit
like the policy though.
Like if you just,
once you've reset beginning your
probability of ending up happens first
time.
Yeah.
But the p the probability that any given
person will end up at zero is the same.
But the probability that you'll end up
the same isn't it?
Cause at the beginning of the game and
you have just as much probability of
moving up to the top as you do a moving
down to the bottom.
Once you write zero though,
you don't get to play anymore.
So at zero your probability of moving up
is zero.
Whereas at the beginning,
your probability of moving up is 50% so
when the gambler's fallacy is merely
that if you keep dumping good money
after bad,
you'll win it back.
You know,
because let's say you've lost 10 times
in a row and you think,
well,
I've lost 10 times in a row,
it's 50 50 I must have a virtually a
hundred percent chance of winning the
next time.
It's like,
well,
no you don't because probability doesn't
have any memory.
That's the gambler's fallacy.
So all right.
Now,
one of the things we might ask ourselves
is this is something that I,
that I discussed with him and lake
because he really thought of this as a
random process and you know,
because he,
he thought here it's very,
very interesting and very complicated.
It's like we know,
for example,
that the Iq distribution in this room is
approximately normal.
And so we can assume that it's a
consequence of random factors.
Okay,
so what,
what do we mean random factors?
Well,
there'd being random genetic things
going on in your lineage since life
began.
And here you are.
You know,
you're smarter than him.
Perhaps.
Why?
Well,
we're going to eliminate the
environmental effects for now.
Just forget about them.
We're going to assume that everybody's
been raised in an environment where they
had enough to eat and where they have
enough resources,
um,
informational resources so that their
intellect can capitalize.
So none of you people have been starved
for information or food.
So I would say in many ways the
important variation in the environment
is already be.
Now your note for most of,
not completely.
Okay.
So it's random occurrences in the past
and the evolutionary history that's put
you wherever the hell you are and the Iq
distribution.
So you're the beneficiary of random
forces.
So he thought of the problem is being
random all the way down to the bottom.
Now the problem I have with that is wait
a second,
we have evidence that some things
predict where you're going to end up in
the distribution.
And so what are those things?
Well,
Iq,
conscientiousness,
emotional stability,
openness.
If it's a creative product.
And then some other smattering of
personality features depending on the
particular domain.
So for example,
if you want to be a salesperson,
some extroversion is huge,
is useful.
If you want to be a manager,
it tends to be better if you're
disagreeable to some degree rather than
if you're agreeable.
If you want to be a nurse or a
caretaker,
then agreeableness is useful.
But the big performance predictors
across time,
our intelligence and conscientiousness.
Now if the damn game is random,
which the statistics seem to indicate,
or at least that you can model it using
processes that model random processes.
Why in the world do Iq and
conscientiousness,
we'll just stick with those two for now.
Why in the world do they predict
success?
So does anybody have any ideas about
that?
Let's start with Iq.
Mean for example,
if you apply your Iq to the stock
market,
if I distribute do you all a bunch of
money and I,
and I mentioned your Iq and I said,
okay,
put together a portfolio.
You get to pick 30 stocks,
you can't sell them for a year.
You get to sell them at the end of the
year.
Um,
what's the probability that the high Iq
people would pick a better set of stocks
than the low Iq?
People
answer that as far as I can tell,
is zero.
It's not.
It's not going to because you can't pick
stocks.
As it turns out,
all the information has already eaten
up.
So I,
and,
and the stock market's an interesting
analogy of the environment,
right?
Do you know what I mean?
Because the stock market is basically an
index of continually transforming human
economic and social environment.
It's basically random.
You can't predict the damn thing,
even if you're smart.
So why is it that smart people when
across time,
and then again,
why is it that hard working people cross
time?
It'd be imagined each peg on the golden
or as like a choice point in life.
Then if people with a higher ed,
you are more likely to choose the choice
point that will be done,
you know?
No,
but that's only a restatement of what I
just said.
It's not a causal account.
You're basically saying that the high Iq
people make better choices.
Yeah.
But that's,
if it's a random environment,
how can they,
I'm thinking instead of money,
we can view it as opportunities and
genetics,
which make somebody adoptable multiple
environments and each coin flip as each
subsequent generation of that lineage.
So that there is an increase.
Like the more adoptable genetics,
emotional stability and situational
wealth you have,
the more likely your next generation has
it.
You know,
like they have to lose a lot more to get
them to zero.
Okay.
So what about a given individual though?
Forget about some being,
forget about it.
Planning across time.
And that's also a weird thing because
some of the single celled organisms that
you,
that were your ancestors 3 billion years
ago are still single celled organisms.
Whereas here you are,
you know,
same environment,
roughly speaking.
So there's this tremendous branching of
possibility across time.
And you might say,
well Iq is adaptive,
which is a terrible word.
Adaptive.
It's like,
yeah,
okay,
so how do you account for all the single
celled organisms?
They're just not that bright.
But there they are.
There's broad,
there's more of them by weight than
there are of us people by weight.
So I probably think this out a bunch of
different ways and you can,
you can think about this and see what
you think.
I mean the first thing that seems to be
to be the cases that you don't have to
play one game,
you know,
like imagine that you're sitting around
with your friends and there were 50
board games going on and you can keep a
hand in,
in each of them.
Well then at some point in one of the
board games,
you're going to start to amass some
success,
right?
Just by chance.
And if you're playing 50 board games in
25 of them after playing for some time,
you're going to be at the top of it.
You know when you're going to be moving
towards the top 50% rather than the
Bordeaux,
we might say,
okay,
play 50 games played 20 turns.
Throw away the ones that you're doing
the worst yet,
the 5% that you're doing the worst yet.
And then just keep doing that until you
end up with the one game that you win.
And maybe you can do that better if you
have high Iq cause you're faster.
So maybe you all you can.
All that happens is that if you're smart
is that you can play many games faster.
And as a consequence of that,
you can choose the ones that you seem to
be winning and stick with those.
And then maybe what happens with
conscientiousness is that you actually
stick to them.
So that means that you actually don't
have to predict the future.
In order to master it.
It means that you have to simulate
multiple futures,
keep your options open,
and sort of play dynamically as the
environment unfolds.
So now it might be more complicated than
that because it's also possible that in
some environments,
at least for local periods of time,
the,
the game is actually not random.
You know?
So it's,
it's funny like if,
do you think money is the monopoly
random?
What do you think?
You've all who everybody hears played
monopoly,
I presume,
right?
Is there anybody who hasn't?
Okay.
So what,
what do you think?
Did the smart people win monopoly more
often?
I think it's the people that
you do you think so you would say it's
the conscientious people that win more
often
what each move too?
Yeah.
Well it's pretty clear that you can,
you can lose stupidly in monopoly,
right?
Although I'm not sure if you can win
intelligently,
you know,
you can avoid obviously bad choices.
Like one choice would be don't buy any
property and just hold onto your money.
That seems to be a losing strategy.
Right?
So that'll wipe me out.
So maybe another thing that smart people
can do is that they don't do things that
are self evidently.
Okay.
That,
that make it certain that you will lose.
It might be something like that.
So,
all right.
So one of the things we might ask
ourselves too is given that Iq and and
conscientiousness do predict success,
how much success do they predict across
talk?
And the answer to that is
they predict a substantial amount.
If you combine our Iq and personality,
I'll show you the equations.
These were formulated in the 1990s.
So we're going to look at this here.
So,
um,
let me walk you through it a bit.
Okay,
so this is a spreadsheet I put together
quite a long time ago.
It's a little bigger so you can see it.
So here's what,
here's the elements of the,
of the equation.
So you need to know,
Ooh,
first element in equation,
how many people?
So we're going to say,
well,
how powerfully can you predict the
performance outcome of people across
time?
And were they the value we're going to
use his dollar value and dollars are
basically,
they're sort of like a,
they're obviously they're the universal
currency because you can trade money in
for virtually anything.
So we use dollars as their standard of
value.
Um,
the first question might be,
well,
how many people do you want to predict
for?
So let's say we're going to take 10.
So He'd,
we put that in this part of the equation
here,
10 people.
Then you might say,
well,
over what period of time do you want to
calculate their success?
And one decent answer is five years
because people seem to stay in the same
job position or career position for
about five years,
although that shortening,
okay,
so that's another thing that you guys
should keep in mind.
You probably not going to be in the same
position in your life for more than
about five years at a time.
And so you have to plan and plot for
dynamic transformations in your career
and you have to do that in a way that,
um,
that,
that works to your advantage,
which partly means you have to keep
options open and you have to be able to
say no.
So,
okay,
the next thing you might ask yourself
is,
well,
how high a predictor,
what's the Roi for your predictor of
what's the correlation coefficient?
And we put together a neuropsychological
battery.
Um,
I published the results of this with,
uh,
with uh,
with,
uh,
someone named Dan Daniel Higgins quite a
long time ago.
We used neuropsychological battery
looking at dorsal lateral prefrontal
ability,
which we thought of as something
potentially from fluid intelligence,
which problem but which probably just
turned out to be quite a good measure of
fluid intelligence.
And we also used conscientiousness and
we found that when we validated that in
a,
we validated it in a factory and we
looked at the performance of the
administrators and managers in the
factory because they had relatively
complex jobs and we had access to seven
years of their performance records,
which someone else had gathered
independently of us.
And what we found was that for those
people who had performance records that
were more than four years old,
we could predict their performance at
about 0.59 about about 0.6 tremendously
powerful prediction.
Now one of the things we found was that
the degree to which our predictions were
accurate increased with the increase in
the number of years of performance data
we have.
So,
for example,
if I want to predict how you do next
year and then I'd get a performance it,
you enter a new job and I get a
performance index after your first year,
I'm not going to be able to predict out
very well from your intelligence and
your conscientiousness because the
measure of your performance actually
won't be very good because it turns out
that you can't even figure out how well
someone is performing in a job until
about three years.
So it turns out that if you take a
complex job on,
you get better and better at it over
three years if you're going to get
better and better at it.
And so we can't tell how well you're
doing until about that period of time.
So that's another thing that's useful to
know.
By the way,
when you guys go off to find your next
complex role in life,
you can't really expect to be good at
what you're going to do until about
three years.
After about four years,
additional experience doesn't seem to
matter.
So that's also worth knowing.
So you're going to feel like a bloody
moron for the first bit of your new job.
And that's because you are,
but you,
you,
if you keep at it,
you'll accrue,
um,
experience and,
and,
and expertise quite rapidly over a three
year period.
And that's probably the right amount of
time over which to evaluate your
performance because you need to know
that,
right?
Should you be freaking out if after six
months you're not doing a good job,
well you got to see how you're doing
compared to your peers.
Hopefully you're not doing a worse job
than them,
but if it's a complex job,
it's going to take you a long time to
master it.
So,
okay,
so anyways,
our predictor was 0.59,
which we are pretty damn thrilled about
and we are comparing that.
We're going to compare that to a
comparison predictor of zero.
For now zero is random.
So if I was going to predict your
trajectory through life,
let's say I want to predict your
industrial productivity.
I'll take 10 of you.
I'm going to,
I'm going to predict your industrial
productivity over the next five years.
That's,
that'll be the goal.
Um,
or we can do this.
I will do this a slightly different way.
Um,
let's see.
So that's the selection ratio.
The last one is the selection ratio.
So let's say,
um,
I wanted to select you guys for a
position at a,
uh,
let's say you're going to be managers in
a,
in a,
in a relatively complex corporate
organization,
there's about 110 of you or something
like that in here.
Now maybe let's say a hundred.
Say I'm going to pick 10 of you.
That means my selection ratio is right
there.
It's one,
it's,
it's one in 10 that you can transform
that into a standard score of 1.76.
Now,
it's important to know how many people
you get to choose from.
Because if you're going to hire one
person and you only have one applicant,
there's not a lot of sense doing any
selection because you only have one
applicant.
So I don't care how much you knew about
that person.
It's not going to be helpful if you have
to hire them.
But in this situation,
we're going to assume that I can screen
all 100 of you and only recommend 10.
Okay?
So we're going to assume you have to put
in a variable for job complexity because
the relationship between intelligence
and conscientiousness increases the
relationship between intelligence,
conscientiousness and predictive power
increases.
As the job becomes more complicated,
she's is exactly what you'd expect,
right?
So if you can do a job by wrote,
all that Iq would conscientiousness will
predict is how fast you can learn it.
But if it's a dynamic job where you have
to make decisions not on a nonstop
basis,
then Iq and conscientiousness are going
to predict your performance over the
long run.
So we're going to assume that you're in
a complex job.
We're gonna assume that you have an
annual salary of $75,000 so then the
question is armed with that knowledge,
how much money would the company that's
using my products obtain by using the
selection compared to with,
if they just picked 10 of you randomly,
and the answer is right there
in five years
they would have made $4 million more
than they would've if they would've just
picked randomly.
And that would be a productivity
increase of 104%
so there,
that's graft here.
So with random selection,
50% of the people you hire are going to
be above average and 50% are going to be
below.
And using a good psychometric battery,
you can get that to vote 80 20 and the
consequence of that is
$4 million in increased productivity.
So now we're going to turn that into one
person.
So over five years,
if you selection processes properly,
you make $400,000 more by hiring one
better person,
it's $40,000 it's what is that to
$100,000 a year?
It's actually more than you're paying
them in salary.
And now the reason for that,
there's a bunch of reasons.
The first reason is,
is that there are tremendous amounts.
There's tremendous differences in
individual productivity.
Now,
one of the things that's weird about
these formulas is this formula is
predicated on the idea that productivity
is actually normally distributed,
but actually productivity is prieto
distributed.
So what that means is that the basic
consequence of using this sort of
prediction is probably higher than this
formula indicates.
Now,
there's a variety of reasons to know.
This.
One is obviously the practical idea.
The practical idea is of what use is it
knowing something about the people that
you're going to hire and that's or work
with?
And the answer to that is it depends on
what you know.
But if the things that you know are
valid and they include personality and
intelligence,
it's not only valuable to know it,
it's virtually vital because the success
of your enterprise will depend on the
people that you hire an associate with.
The second thing is I think that knowing
this should change the way that you look
at the world.
If you understand that the outcomes in
life are distributed on a prieto
distribution and that there are in belt
temperamental factors that play an
important role in determining that one
of the problems that you have before you
as modern people is what the hell do you
do about that?
From a conceptual,
social,
political and economic perspective?
Because nobody who's currently
considering how societies are structured
pays any attention to this sort of
thing.
They don't assume that there are
differences between people with regards
to their life outcome chances,
not of this sort of magnitude.
And so none of the social policies that
we have in place reflect any of this.
And so I would say like our
psychometrics are 21st century in our
political and economic theories are
basically 17th century and it's not a
good thing and you guys are going to
suffer for this or benefit from it
because as society becomes more
technological and as it transforms more
and more rapidly,
the degree to which the prieto
distribution is going to kick in is
going to increase.
Now you already see that.
That's why that the separation between
rich and poor in industrialized
countries is becoming increasingly
severe.
Now,
that's modified by some degree to the
fat by the fact that the middle class
worldwide is growing like mad.
And so that's a really good thing.
But still the longterm plays the prieto
distribution,
and it's partly because an person is one
thing,
but an intelligent person with infinite
computational power.
That's a completely different thing,
and that's where we're headed.
So I don't know exactly what to make of
all this sort of thing politically,
but I know that to the degree that we
ignore it,
we're going to have very unhappy and and
unstable societies.
So we'll see you Thursday on that happy
note.
Let's see you Thursday.